字幕君
哥 你去哪了
我這過不來啊
你不能這樣 萬華茶室關了
我今天又沒關
不過你穿的顏色跟那個也蠻像的
我是開心啊 對不對
那是紅燈區嘛
你就是G燈
我們是不是
歌有仇必爆的第二季開始前
要先講一些景語
講景語
因為這個頻道很多新觀眾來
沒搞懂我們的傳統跟優秀的歷史
這要講一下
有人沒看過
還有我們是正經八百
我們是會開車的
我們是來開車的
本節目有大量不移而同的內容
有那麼誇張嗎
有一點啦 有一點
因為你知道我最討厭有人會說
你們前面不要閒聊好不好
聊天宇宙三幹嘛
欸 重點就在這閒聊好不好
新來的不要囉嗦好不好
新來的
閒聊 我們常常閒聊裡面很多智慧在裡面
沒有錯 開車也需要公力
對 不容易好不好
我們是沒有Ray的脫口秀演員
最近脫耳朽很紅
你知道嗎
龍老K
K也好
所以我們先把金宇上在前面
但是很開心歌有仇必報
終於願意來錄第二季
第二季
對啊
因為要打第二季了
所以也要來錄第二季
要打第二季了
這叫諧音梗
那你的第二季打什麼呢
第二季打AZ
跟第一季一樣
都打AZ
所以我們來看一下這個AV的效果怎麼樣
第二季
來幫大家也要強心增打第二季
其實錄這個蠻開心的你知道嗎
我以前走在路上沒什麼人認識
錄完這個之後
因為我剛剛看
哇這個第一集
13040萬人看
第一季的第一集
130幾萬的觀看
哇好多喔
我現在走在路上
走在路上那個人一看到我就這樣比比比
你你你你你
他還沒講說
你是不是有在做股票
對 你怎麼知道
你是不是做不三個好
太極王算密的
不是啦 因為做股票
做不大好的時候就會想去網路上學習
一學習一看哪個點閱率最高
哎呀 就看到我們的歌友走必報
因為點閱率蠻高的
非常高
很多學員都這樣子買的
而且顏色又很鮮明
也很鮮明
看看不會打瞌睡
也不會打瞌睡
也不會睡覺
所以我們今天第一集
就要為這些散戶而做
好 我們來講一個主題
跟散戶有絕大的關係
好的
歡迎收看理財達人秀
歌有仇必報第二季
有沒有要做一點效果
很開心喔
小歌終於又回來錄我們
籌碼單元的第二季囉
大家是不是已經敲碗敲到碗都破了
尤其是最近整個大盤的氣氛
不是很理想的時候
其實看籌碼格外重要
我們常提醒大家
籌碼就是市場上有人把錢拿出來
真金白銀的再進出
這個是最真實的
所以了解籌碼對你投資理財
才會有幫助
剛剛小哥也提到
很多人是怎麼樣股票最近做不好
網路搜尋
就搜尋到我們理財丹宇
恭喜你喔
這是一個超佛星頻道
裡面保障非常多
包括我們第二季的歌有仇必報
一定要好好的學習
今天講什麼呢
今天我們來講一個東西
跟散戶息息相關
就是融資
好 常常聽到大家說
殺融資啦
融資洗乾淨啦
散戶的融資
難道真的那麼不值錢
那麼可憐嗎
我們今天聽小哥來說分明
好
首先我们来看融资
融资先来看一下大盘的融资
好 常常听到这件事
融资维持率低于多少
融资减了多少
是的
我们先看大盘的融资
赵凡你记得吗
今年大盘在什么时候最热
大盘今年4月底有一波很热
上1万7
到6月份的时候
人人都是航海王 钢铁王
那時候呢
一堆人用融資
買航運股
買鋼鐵股
尤其是六月底的時候
那時候瘋了
當然啦
我跟你講
那個時候很多人跟我說
趙華你有沒有買航運股
沒有啊
你知不知道
連我們家的工讀生
都會買航運股
你在幹嘛啊你
那時候我的健身教練
健身教練
我要停一下
我的健身教練跟我講
哥我要不要買航運股
我說連你這個都不懂股票的再問
航運股我看是凶多吉少了
難怪他都沒有專心幫你健身
那時候問完呢
大概還剩下最後一根漲停
後面就開始一泄千里了
那我們看大盤融資在什麼時候
來到了最高峰
就在7月初的時候
那時候到18034
就是航運類股在最高點的時候
那時候這個融資水位
一度到達了3000億
3000億的融資在上面
借錢買股票
哇很多
一堆人手上的錢定存解約
用融資去買航運股
哇很慘
為什麼很慘呢
我們從最近就可以看到
最近在前幾天融資在這裡
做大幅的撤退
那這種撤退
很多都是被逼的
你說是因為被斷頭嗎
被斷頭了
因為之前還沒有大幅撤退
之前還會撐
這個收到追剿信了
哎呀 那就再入點錢
那最近怎麼樣 撐不下去了
沒有潛入了
直接自己砍
不然就被券商砍
自己砍我們叫做自殺
自攻
不能講殺
那個他人砍
他攻
那我們看最近這個融資水位
只剩下2400億 2472
從高檔算下來
這個融資大概少了兩成
好像也不多啊
不過這個我們看這個
加減指數高檔下來才跌了一成
融資退的比跌幅多
對 那這個我們看起來比較健康
比較健康 那假如融資退的比跌幅少那就小心 那可能會繼續跌那這個看起來還好啦好 但是小哥我這邊要幫散戶朋友說句話好的
借錢買股票好不好
雖然我們講風險很高
但是有錢賺天金地益
你怎麼能說我借錢買股票
就是我的錯
我買越多反而還害大盤跌越多
因為你借錢買股票太明顯了
大家一看融資上升那麼多
散戶來了
此时不割更代何时
赏物就韭菜嘛
你看融资那么
你看一些行业类股
高档主力卖融资喷出
不趁这时候割什么时候割
所以我们融资要好好学
好 我们了解一下
有常听到一些融资的名词
到底代表什么意思
融资我们现在都知道了
借钱买股票就融资
融资名词
首先第一个看融资增减
那融資增等於看多
看多是說
用融資買股票的這個人看多
就這個人看多而已
等於看多的人變多
對 就這個人看多
不代表你要看多
這個人看多搞不好是
這是反指標
你可以看空的
所以這個看多只是這個人看多而已
那融資減就這個人
這個融資的人他看空
他也可以獲利了絕
因為他覺得不會漲上去了
或者是他覺得會跌得更慘
他就只要把這個融資賣掉
這個我們叫做看空
那也是這個人看空而已
那整體上看多看空
我們待會會比較詳細講
那第二個是融資的餘額
什麼叫餘額
融資餘額就是
這檔股票到底有多少融資在裡面
叫融資餘額
那融資宜爾就是一檔股票融資章數的家總
宜爾你會以為是剩下來的
其實不是
是多少人在融資買這檔股票
像這邊比較高的就是友達
群創 華邦電
這些比較大型的股票
他們覺得跌得好便宜
對 很多用融資買
做做善事融資買的
對 沒錯
好 第三是看融資的維持率
那融資維持率是股票的限值
除以融資的金額
這個我們有個法律的規定
小於130%要追繳
所以這個融資維持率
130% 就很重要
以前是120
後來發現 政府發現不行
120太低了
120他大概輸一輸
大概沒什麼錢拿回家
現在把拉高到130
是為了保護就對了
保护它 至少它輸一輸
可是這樣更快就出去了
還有錢吃飯 那也好啦
更快出去 停損點早一點
那不然這個維持率小於120
這個賣賣也沒什麼錢了
第四個是融資的使用率
什麼叫使用率
融資的使用率是融資餘額除以融資的限額
為什麼還要限勒
我看到我的APP有時候打開
他写融資無限
融券會寫幾張
通常那種無限
他認為說你買不到那麼多
他寫無限
有的時候融資剩10張可以買
我比較少看到這樣
融券真的會只有張數
融券常常都沒有融券
融資我們很少看到
但是也有
融資你看到融資剩下很少張可以買
這時候你注意
融資假如不大能買
然後維持率又很低的話
這張股票準備崩跌了
因為你想想看
大戶或主力或散戶
他原本是買融資的
結果他現在連攤品都沒得攤
你攤品拿現金來
融資都不讓你攤
所以這個融資使用率過高
其實對股票也不大
融資維持率不能太低
對不對 融資使用率不能太高
這個使用率有沒有一個標準較高
有 融資使用率
融資使用率超過70%
那是超級高 70%
70%是天險的
70%大概融資維持率再低
那個就多殺多
我曾經空過一檔股票
融資使用率高達99%
什麼東西啊
結果空完之後
你知道發生什麼事嗎
兩天之後他就暫停交易了
他就出事了
他就是融資使用率太高
然後維持率太低
暫停交易你的獲利怎麼算
暫停交易很麻煩的
對啊 你看
我有一堆融券
我要在市場上問人家說
你有融資嗎
要不要跟我兩個合併一下
因為你要回補嘛
對啊 那我還算蠻有良心的
那一檔我記得我是用7塊錢跟他對敲
那就有一天他開始交易之後
連續跌停一直到3塊錢才打開跌停
你不該那麼早回覆 我算有良心
沒關係啦 那個我們少賺一點
讓他少賠一點 好
那我們來介紹一下
什麼叫融資維持率
那融資維持率過低會斷頭
首先我們來看這個大家都很關心的
大家人手一張的
50萬的股東 長榮
50萬股東 好可憐
好 那我們用最近股價來算
最近股價
最近你用92.4元
假设你买一张的话
好 买一张要92,400元
融资金额代表你借的钱
你借的钱是5万5元
大概借6成
借6成 你准备4成就可以了
你准备37,000大概就可以买一张了
37,000买一张
那融资维持率呢
我们就是用92除以5万5
再乘100%等于166
好 这是刚开始的时候
你一建仓 假设你借六成的
你的维持率就是166%
然后呢 什么时候会追缴
各位记得
就是股价乘以0.78
这真的是蛮令人觉得不舒服的惩罚
对 反正看这个数字也不大好记
原来这很好记
就是0.78的时候你就差不多了
心里觉得很7.8的时候
就是要被追缴了
所以你買92塊72塊會追繳
買100塊78塊追繳
買200塊的 哇塞早就追繳了
這個長榮有一對買在200多的
以後都要跟他的孫子講
這是你阿公
當年買的長榮230
別人隔日沖 他隔代沖
隔日賣不掉
而且長榮因為有個股期
那時候還調高了個股期的保證金
跟融資一樣那時候保證金到25%很逼人 沒有 40对对对对那处置那段时间对那很逼人对40%
跟融资差不多了
所以你期货的人也得砍
融资的人也得砍
好可怕
对没错
好
那这个融资
今天我们介绍融资使用率
好 融资使用率
不要太高
是使用额度除以可用额度
对
那我们看美德伊
美德伊之前融资使用率很高
那我們看最近的使用率呢
還是蠻高的
還有21%
21%算高嗎
你剛說到70%
70%是天險是非常高
那帶有多少以上我們就要注意
大概20%以上要注意
我們就要注意了
20%我覺得還好
20%以上就是有人在買
到70%那就是非常極度高了
那這個美德宜
其實他的融資已經有被斷過一陣子了
所以可能減少了
對 美德宜最高價到78塊
然後怎麼又是78
今天只剩12塊
那所以呢這種股票
像美德這種股票
他就是符合了多殺多
多殺多
說到這個三指標必關注
第一個融資使用率高
假如超過70%的話
這是一個天險
可是小哥其實有提到70%是天險
也許是50%
我們就特別要留意
因為就算融資很多了
那第二個呢
農資維持率低 小於120%
雖然政府規定是130
但是我們因為有平均嘛
所以120差不多
130是說你整體的戶頭
對
那很多人手上不可能只有一檔
很多兩三檔
所以個股呢
假如小於120%
這個就要小心了
第三個呢 主力長期的賣出
你的長期多長
長期賣出
大概這個月主力都在賣方
那就算長期了
一個月就可以了
好 那我們最近有幾檔股票
我從這個大數據裡面撈
好 我撈了幾檔
我覺得比較要小心了
第一個是4967的實權
好 記憶體熱門的時候
也是高當充比率的個股
那時候股價很高 有沒有看到
那時候我們來看一下
這個股價在高檔
這張表我們特別看
股價在高檔嗎
股價高檔主力在幹嘛
到貨 高檔主力到貨
然後融資在幹嘛
融資在買進 減貨
所以一看就知道
又是散戶被騙到山上去了
散戶被騙上去
然後騙完了之後
這個股價就開始下跌
那這條線叫做融資的成本
融資還可以有成本線
對 那融資現在成本
平均成本在哪邊
在59.95
不得了
現在股價剩多少 股價剩40塊
對
所以它的融資維持率剩下111%
低於120了
哇賽 集體斷頭的年代 這很低
那使用率還有48%
還這麼多人在上面
對呀 所以這種股票
你真的要小心一點
這種股票真的大家沒有看理財達人秀
因為記憶體反轉
我們應該很早就講了
它就是記憶體的公司
所以我們說理財達人秀是佛心的節目
是真的啊
你要長期看
因為你知道我們這樣講別人
我都會接到恐嚇電話
我業績現在還很好 沒什麼講我
可是就是整個產業景氣是反轉
籌碼爛 你業績好
我們看過很多
你的營收的高點
落在股價的高點後一個月
也就是說主力已經在出貨了
但是營收還在創高
一個月算不錯了
你們要看驅動IC
股價高點在4月底
9月還很多家在創新高
哇塞 那是很多人
套到覺得莫名其妙
奇怪 我的股票打5折
為什麼贏收創新高
就這樣子 好
實權這樣 這個要小心點
是 好 接下來我們來看
4133的亞諾法 生計股
生計股
這個去年呢
他因為疫情的關係
也是很火紅的股票
可是呢 他在高檔的時候
我們來看高檔的時候
主力在幹嘛 主力在到貨囉
這主力真的蠻厲害
對 而且你看這主力
一买一卖
趁着一买一卖的时候到货
隔日冲
就是有隔日冲进来
拉涨停出掉 拉涨停出掉
然后在这边到货
那我们来看在到货的过程中
融资进来了
是 融资被骗进来了
融资觉得现在疫情那么严重
对 要有点生计股才安心
他就要来买亚洛法
就一买了那时候80块
现在剩下35块
然后融资最近并没有大幅的减少
都在撑
都在撐喔 使用率還有26%
可能覺得很便宜了吧
因為疫情不是前一陣子又
豐聲鶴唳的
可是這個現在慢慢的
疫苗大家都打了
加零的天數也變多了
那以後也可能也會解封
所以這種股票要小心一點
為什麼 因為它的維持率剩下111%
好低啊 很低啊
所以你有這種股票要小心一點
這個比較恐怖啦
不過我還是要說
借錢買股票也是聰明人的玩法
對 也有
散戶當然你說可能趨勢看不對
像剛剛講的很多圖都是主力倒給散戶
但很多主力也會槓桿
他借錢買股票就很厲害
對 真的有這種厲害的主力
怎麼分
那我教你分
這個融資有分
主力融資買進
還有散戶融資買進
融資有兩種就對了
對 私有兩種 資資有兩種
那這主力融資買進呢
你會看到怎麼樣
第一個融資增加
第二個主力買進
第三個籌碼集中度會提高
主力可以買比較多張嘛
大戶
那第二個產物融資買進
你會看到融資也是增加
那主力賣出 賣給你
那籌碼集中度呢
一人一張 很分散
是這樣子的
好 那散戶融資到底要怎麼樣
才可以清洗乾淨呢
這個首先呢
我們這樣講
第一個
經過我大數據研究之後
對 我發現
只要融資可以減少70%
等一下
你要有七成的資金賣掉
這發生什麼慘劇
第一個跌太多
一直跌一直跌
然後撐不住了
第二個是盤太久
盤太久也會洗融資
一直跌 一直盤
稍微漲一下 它就賣掉
因為太無聊了
這個股價不太動
那後面它也會減少
第二個呢
這個融資減少的幅度
只要可以大於股價的跌幅
那我們以三個月為觀察區間
這樣子的話它就比較容易清洗乾淨比較容易清洗乾淨像你剛好講的大盤其實跌不到兩成可是融資少兩成其實好事算好事 真的那個籌碼算是清洗得不錯
對
那很多都是最近被斷頭的
我覺得用清洗蠻殘忍的
好像是 對
人家又沒有弄髒
幹嘛清洗
清洗對不對
好 接下來我們來看這個
融資的清洗度
清洗肚
首先融資最多的就是友達
友達我們來看前陣子
在這個高點的時候
在這裡
在這邊我們看
這個融資就是可憐的融資
因為主力在賣超了
融資進來買
主力賣超融資進來買
然後就被套在上面
然後股價都沒什麼動
好無聊
景氣循環上一波
已經在低點的時候
不會動的
不會動
那后面还曾经刹到变6块
那在最高点的时候
那融资有到40万张
那一路一直盘一直盘
那在盘的过程中
融资就开始跌了
那融资跌了
融资最低点在这里
跌到剩下6万张
这个不要小看
它从2017年
洗到2019年
洗到你脱皮
因为说真的
大家说景气循环股
經濟徐環股就是這樣
他一次下來的時候
三四年沒有開張
每天很無聊
每天盤一直線這樣子
真的很可怕要注意這件事
那後面洗完之後
就準備往上攻了
準備往上攻了
那怎麼突然跌一段
那是剛好遇到了新冠疫情
剛好跟大家一起
對 那假如沒有遇到新冠疫情的話
其實就一路往上攻到35塊
是
那這個遇到新冠疫情之後
後面這個漲很多
為什麼可以漲這麼多呢
就是因為他融資剩下6萬
後面主力就開始買
他融資又開始進場
這個就是有清洗過
再供一波的案例
融資剛進場沒有關係
不可能融資都不進場
剛好面板又遇到景氣循環又向上囉
所以這一波是大家都賺
可是等他再回到景氣循環往下的時候
那融資要注意的 最近增加好多
好 那這種融資清洗很多的
很容易後面有一段行情
再看第二個案例
第二個案例是華邦電
也是景氣循環股
對 好 那華邦電呢
我們來看一下 在這一段
各位記得這個景氣循環股
就像航運股一樣
這散戶很喜歡買在什麼地方你知道嗎
買在大賺錢的時候
賺錢嘛
或者呢 少要喜歡買在3的右邊
就是已經股價高峰過了
因為創高之後 像說長榮有230的價值啊
我現在160 150買怎麼看都覺得划算
而且對應其他的EPS好便宜喔
對啊 這本益比很低
很低呢 我套牢沒關係 我領股力就好了
8月你說還在創新高啊
對啊 那股力最好可以領好幾年了
那只領一年的話
這種股力還是不要領比較好
好 那我们看在主力卖超的时候
你看这股价已经创新高
创新高主力在到货了
融资进来
所以融资的最高点有到13万张
那后面股价就一路跌一路跌一路跌
那融资后面也一路跌一路跌一路跌
因为融资后面受不了了嘛
那受不了之后
这个融资从13万张剩下36000张
这也是少了七成
少了7成 好
他在這邊呢
這融資跌到低點之後
他這邊整理完也準備往上供了
無奈又遇到疫情
遇到疫情之後呢
最低點到9.8%
後面供了一波
股價大概漲了快4倍了
那在這一段呢
融資從13萬到3600
股價從19塊跌到10塊
那這個就是融資跌幅到了70%
股價跌幅了這個快50%
這就算是一個清洗的蠻乾淨的
洗得有乾淨
好 但是最近是不是融資
也有在被洗的第二波
最近我們來看主力在高漲
主力又在賣了
融資又進來了
所以又在開始上一次的循環
最近這洗的
一不曉得要洗多久了
因為小哥舉這個例子
我覺得要提醒觀眾朋友
這不是洗一兩個月
他這個景氣循環股洗兩年
洗三年都有
所以不要一看到說
融資現在降了你進去
可能你要再等兩年
它才會再起來
這算是好的景氣循環
我們來看
它的高點是2017年
最近是2011年 跟一百一樣
才4年
這算是好股票來著
有些股票
你還記得被動元件嗎
你說1300的嗎
18年
你還記得閃裝航運嗎
閃裝航運我記得也十幾年
其實還有像
還有像
吞回去
小心
有些股票這個
這個一個回合好幾年了
所以這個不要隔代衝
好 不要隔代衝
對啦
好 今天教大家融資
融資就是比較是散戶的動態
尤其是散戶非常樂觀
非常看多的時候會進場
所以有時候說割韭菜割散戶
就是因為太樂觀了
因為散戶說實話跟市場有資訊不對稱的問題
所以不是說暢衰散戶的融資
是很血淋淋很殘忍的歷史上
它就是一個繁指標
好那我們在進階的榮耀班
還要來教大家什麼呢
就是教大家如何把這個融資
跟主力的買賣操作結合
會來教你有四個項限
融資增 主力買 融資增 主力賣
融資減 主力買 融資減 主力賣
趙華完全沒有說錯
怎麼來看這四個象限
股票會不會漲都在我們的榮耀班喔
好 今天非常謝謝小哥
重新回到我們理財達人秀
回到趙華的懷抱喔
做我們的歌有仇必報
第二季的第一集
這一集裡面教大家看融資喔
那我覺得這一集有一個很大的心得
小哥舉的很多例子叫做
景氣循環股
我知道很多人現在會有一個迷思
覺得他們EPS好高喔
現在股價跌下來很便宜
融資也有在退喔
是不是退到可以買
不要忘記
剛剛舉的例子很多要洗幾年
洗三年 洗四年
它的景氣循環才會再回到往上喔
所以這就是為什麼達人
做常常很良心的告訴大家
景氣循環股反轉的時候
不要亂碰它
好 希望今天的歌有仇必爆
第二季第一集帶給你滿滿的收穫
我們下次再見囉
掰掰
by bwd6